bueno los primeros resultados se van a
empezar a conocer según anunciaron desde
el ministerio del interior- posiblemente
antes de las 22 horas argentinas decir
un esos son unas 4 horas después del
cierre de unas incluso antes con un
porcentaje tal vez no tanto 20 30 por
ciento de los votos creen que pueden ya
tener una tendencia y ahí hay dos
elementos yo diría muy muy importantes
por un lado mirar cómo termina la
composición del senado ocho provincias
votan en senadores depende de cómo quede
compuesta la cámara el oficialismo
perdería ahí el quórum propio y es un
espacio clave porque allí preside la
vicepresidenta la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández de kirchner y si
pierden fuerza ahí van a tener
bloqueadas muchas iniciativas y por otro
lado pueden llegar a dejar de ser
primera minoría en la cámara de
diputados con lo cual verían últimos dos
años de gobierno de muchísima
negociación para poder sacar adelante
las políticas que quieran implementar
especialmente una vez pasado el momento
más crítico de la pandemia en argentina